so i got cast at 12 years old and that's
obviously
just the spongiest most absorbent time
in your life
and again a time of just self-discovery
and there's just so many things that are
happening and changing and just you know
again i have five brothers and sisters
and they're going up and we're figuring
out our dynamic
and um you know the concept of the show
is that when i would alter my image
and i would put on a wig and i would you
know put on sparkly things
that i held a new value that i was
valuable
um it did translate into my real life
there was
a different level of like hysteria
when hannah mon i mean it was actually
kind of crazy being hannah montana
now i have a hard time remembering
exactly what that felt like
but um there was you know the way
that kids would react at these like
hannah shows versus when i was myself
and i would meet fans out it was it was
different
and so again on that like kind of
psychological level
um i guess that's kind of why originally
um when i first started doing
like solo projects as my own identity
i'd almost create
kind of alter egos of myself because
i thought you almost that i miley cuz my
name was miley on the show too which it
wasn't you know when my when my friends
from nashville were going to audition
obviously the
the name wasn't miley but i embodied the
character so much
that they the writers thought it made
most sense
for hannah to be miley because of how
much i truly was the character
and it didn't really feel like a
character i just said
okay someone's told me i'm hannah
montana i am now hannah montana and
anything that i create
for her i am in it's like it's beyond
method because
i was growing up as her she was me
like there was no divide between us
that's who i was
there was a 15-year anniversary and this
was 15 years of my show being on air
and i spent the day wow
thinking what do i want to do with my
next 15 years
that was what i dedicated my day to and
usually i would feel i wasn't doing
enough if i wasn't
you know talking with the fans creating
but i thought
this day is like bigger than it is a
birthday almost to me
and like i really feel we're talking
about spirituality that i needed to
on that day i wrote a letter to hannah
montana from myself oh
[ __ ] and it was about you know
just my gratitude towards the character
what was it suggested
or is this something that you know about
i don't think anyone really could have
told me to do it because a lot of the
people that
are around me now were not in that
three-day car ride with me and my mom
that's strong
that was like it was just
yeah so now so now when i wrote this
letter and i was able to kind of like
make peace with it um i thought
and peace being the kind of key word of
the story is that when i thought what do
i want
the next 15 years what's my cuz i knew
when i was in that car driving the three
days of california
what i wanted i guess these next 15
years to look like i knew what i wanted
so i was able to achieve it because
everything that i did i would know
for a fact if i was taking a step
forward or backwards because i knew my
destination
and i think you know clarity and knowing
what you want you're able to make
each day count so i
really spent this anniversary thinking
about what i wanted
and it's kind of vague but somehow says
any
everything it was about i want to find
peace
the way that people feel that they've
been reborn or saved
i feel that i have been six weeks ago i
feel like everything changed six weeks
ago for me
[Music]
you